in 2014
ukraine erupts into crisis which unfolds
on many levels
first in kiev when massive protests in
the streets lead to the fall of the
government
and the escape of the ousted president
viktor yanukovych
then the situation turns into an
international crisis
as vladimir putin of russia moves in
special forces
in uniforms without emblems and a nexus
crimea
a region of ukraine on the black sea
fighting breaks out in eastern ukraine
between the ukrainian army and rebels
supported by russia
and in july a malaysian airliner is shot
down
as it crosses eastern ukraine with all
passengers and crew killed
a succession of ceasefires are brokered
and then broken
several million become refugees and the
fate
of a nation hangs in the balance
after the collapse of the soviet union
many experts
warned of ethnic violence on a mass
scale in the former soviet union
but it did not occur so why now
for decades after world war ii the
violent changing of borders
had been considered a taboo in europe
given the cascade of turmoil that would
follow
the prospect largely became unthinkable
with the tragic exception of the former
yugoslavia
so 2014 was in a sense a pivotal year
as eastern europe again saw borders
altered by violence
and the threat of force as part of
ukraine crimea
was annexed by russia and putin
announcing
that ukraine as a whole was a failed
state sent his forces
into eastern ukraine and yet
the tinder for this explosion didn't
just spontaneously come into being in
2014.
in fact neither did the larger emergency
about the
recent difficult post-soviet politics of
transition
over the last two or three two to three
decades rather
the background to this crisis is a
slow-motion
identity crisis involving both ukraine
and russia
and extending back over centuries
it has often been noted by scholars that
russia without ukraine is a country
but russia with ukraine is an empire
so one question that arises is what sort
of russia comes into being
if it chooses an imperial identity with
an appetite for expansion
that threatens its neighbors or if on
the contrary
russia chooses a self-sufficient
identity that meshes with modern europe
today
for ukrainians their identities are both
linked to those of a past shared with
russia
but also with historic ties and
affinities with the west
ukraine is marked by a diversity of
historical memories
and orientations and in that sense it's
like a
microcosm of larger eastern european
patterns that we've been exploring in
this course
but with one big difference while many
attributes
of eastern europe's history derived from
the challenges that face
smaller countries and ethnic groups when
they confront bigger outside
imperial powers ukraine is different in
its sheer
size after russia ukraine is the second
largest country in europe
and it's the largest country located
entirely inside europe
ukraine is the size of texas with a
population of 45 million
it became famous as the bread basket of
europe
because of its tremendously fertile
black soil the chernozem
from that rich earth spring up amber
waves of grain
and also fields of sunflowers in this
sense
the flag of independent ukraine blue
over yellow
is in fact a literal rendering of the
landscape
idyllic sky overproductive acres
it also suggests the level flat
geography that has
shaped ukrainian history as a contested
area whose very name
means borderland
the tides of history also carved out
divides in ukraine that still persist
today
after the golden age of the roos
centered on kiev
the mongol invaders swept in after a
time of predominance the mongols areas
of control shrank
leaving the tartars of crimea as their
descendants
then poland and lithuania moved in as
well they left an
imprint on the society and politics of
ukraine
while also endorsing the creation of a
ukrainian union
church orthodox and tradition but bound
to the roman catholic church
ukrainian nobles assimilated to the
manners of the polish elite
beyond the areas of foreign control lay
the wild realm
of the ukrainian cossacks those free
fighters
who escaped feudal regimes in order to
live entirely by their own
independent code like the american
cowboys
cossacks became famous for their
horsemanship their fighting skills
and their rough and tumble independent
ways so
it's little wonder that later ukrainian
romantics
idolize the cossacks and these
mythologized heroes
even show up in ukraine's national
anthem
wedged between the powers of poland
lithuania to the west
and russia in the east the cossacks
maintained a balance between those
powers
until they could do so no longer and had
to choose one or another side for an
alliance
in 1654 the cossack warlord bolton
mitsuki who had led an uprising against
poland
and sought to create an independent
state for the cossacks
signed a treaty with russia at pereaslav
historians have been arguing ever since
for centuries
after about that treaty's true meaning
khmenitsky received in this treaty the
tsar's protection
along with russian promises for
ukrainian autonomy
instead of getting an ally who would
defend their existence however
the cossacks discovered that they now
had a set of new rulers
because in 1667 soon afterwards poland
and russia came to an agreement among
themselves
for partition they divided the contested
ukrainian lands
along the nyeper river throughout this
course
we've seen again and again that
recurring phenomenon
of partitions in eastern europe and
stubborn resistance
against them this partition was
eventually made moot by the decline of
one of the partners poland lithuania
and its division by other great powers
for ukraine the final end of poland
lithuania by 1795
meant that most ukrainians were now in
the russian empire
with one exception the proud province of
galicia in the west
actually fell to austrian rule under the
hopsburgs
so here a new west versus east contrast
emerged in ukrainian history in the
areas under the russian empire
policymakers assumed that the slavic
populations
or little russians as they called them
would eventually
melt into russian culture a greater
whole
the empress catherine the great labeled
the regions that she had won
near the black sea novoracia new russia
a name which clearly pointed to the
intended future of a unified expanded
russian
imperial identity ukrainian language was
banned
books outlawed and nationalist
intellectuals persecuted
but by contrast in the west in the
austrian empire
where the state had to play a
complicated game of
balancing ethnic groups off against one
another
ukrainians or ruthings as they were
formerly called
were actually able to cultivate a modern
national identity
literature and culture
we've noted how the end of world war one
brought some attempts at ukrainian
independence but these failed
between the world wars ukrainians again
found themselves divided by borders
most living in the soviet union others
in poland
romania and czechoslovakia inside the
soviet union as we saw
stalin cracked down on ukrainian
cultural leaders and brought
mass death with the terror famine or
holodomor
of the 1930s with the coming of the
second world war
some ukrainian nationalists hoped that
nazi germany might help their cause
among their leaders was stefan bandera
before the war in poland bandera was
active
in the organization of ukrainian
nationalists which waged a campaign of
assassinations
against polish officials at the start of
the second world war
ukraine some ukrainian nationalists
allied with nazi germany
and some participated in the nazi
campaigns against the jews
but as ukrainian hopes for independence
were frustrated
relations deteriorated and the nazis
arrested
and imprisoned bandera a new force
called the ukrainian insurgent army or
upa arose
opposed to the nazis and soviets and it
violently aimed to ethnically cleanse
poles from the areas that they claimed
killing tens of thousands
by the war's end a strange hidden
three-sided conflict was roaring in
these regions
between banderas ukrainian nationalist
guerrillas
polish underground fighters and soviet
partisans
in a previous lecture we noted how
towards the end of the second world war
borders and populations were shifted in
eastern europe
ukraine saw key examples of this stalin
deported all the crimean tatars from
their homes
expelling them overnight poland shifted
westward
ethnic poles were evicted from ancestral
homes
and the city of became levive
in ukrainian in western ukraine by the
end of this process
ukraine's borders included most
ukrainians
for the first time in centuries but all
of them
under moscow's rigid control
the second world war had uprooted many
and this contributed to a vast diaspora
of ukrainians around the world
but especially in the united states and
in canada they number in the millions
due to repeated waves of immigration or
escape
since the 19th century marina levitzka's
2005 novel
a short history of tractors in ukrainian
is a most engaging comic novel
that depicts all the complexities of
successive
waves of immigrants from ukraine coming
to britain
and their interactions with each other
and with their new home and i recommend
this book most highly
within ukraine partisan warfare
continued
into the 1950s as in the baltics
the guerrilla leader bandera remained in
germany where he was hunted down by the
kgb
and assassinated in munich in 1959
a final change of borders was then
affected by stalin's successor nikita
khrushchev
who had actually been a top party
official in ukraine before and after the
war
to celebrate the successes of the soviet
union
and to mark one particular ancient event
three centuries before
in 1954 khrushchev officially gave
crimea
to the republic of ukraine the old
anniversary that was being marked was
the 1654 treaty of pediaslav
between russia and the cossacks now
given the fact that all the republics in
the soviet union were in fact ruled from
moscow the border change
didn't seem at the time anything more
than a formality but it ended up
ringing down to our times
below the surface of soviet life even as
ukraine's formal existence
was written into the state structure
russification
still preceded a pace in eastern ukraine
a large part of the population were
russian speakers even if they identified
themselves as ukrainians
in the country at large bilingualism was
common
because russian held pride of place as
the language of international
brotherhood in the soviet union
about a quarter of people in ukraine
today identify russian as their mother
tongue
especially in the east
dissident voices in the soviet period
were strongest in the western parts of
ukraine
because of its different history these
were the parts that had been sovietized
more recently and remembered a different
non-soviet past
in the period of glasnost and
gorbachev's reforms
the dissident rook movement which was
the people's movement of ukraine
championed ukrainian identity in ways
that were similar to the independence
movements in the baltics at the time
protests were sparked by the chernobyl
disaster and how the state hid its
impact
so environmental protests grew the
banned uniate church
also resurfaced after being underground
for decades
towards the end of the soviet period
even ukrainian communist officials
endorsed independent statehood with the
collapse of the soviet union in 1991
ukraine became independent in a
referendum on the question
over 90 percent of voters were in favor
of independence
however in what followed the newly
independent ukraine revealed yet more
complexities
along with russia and belarus ukraine
was one of the founding members of the
cis the commonwealth
of independent states yet many ukrainian
leaders
avowed that they wanted to be part of an
eastern european
return to europe as well which would
mean
orienting themselves and ukraine towards
the west and its institutions
how could these commitments be combined
at the same time
the population of independent ukraine
was diverse including
ukrainian-speaking ukrainian ukrainians
ukrainian-speaking russian
ethnic russians jews and crimean tatars
who had migrated back to the homeland
that stalin had once evicted them from
several competing branches of the
orthodox church also claimed the
loyalties
of people of that faith at the same time
both the state and economy were in bad
condition
the slow and very fitful economic
transition
favored those who were well connected so
soon a class of powerful oligarchs rose
up
and these super rich founded political
parties of their own as sort of personal
vehicles for advancement
bribery was an integral part of a an
entire shadow economy that actually
carried over from soviet times
in the year 2000 secret recordings
allegedly
captured the president leonid kuchma's
voice
as he ordered his entourage to
deal with a troublesome muckraking
journalist
and soon after the journalist in
question giorgi gongadze
was later found dead corruption
at multiple levels of government ate
away
at ordinary people's confidence in the
system and economic productivity lagged
ukraine found itself hugely dependent on
russia for energy supplies
some 75 percent of its gas and 80
percent of oil supplies
to overcome its troubles ukraine sought
international financial aid
to prepare for reforms and giving up its
big nuclear stockpile
left over from the soviet era in 1994
helped win them some international
assistance
over time disappointment with insider
politics as usual
produced a popular movement called the
orange revolution
in ukraine in 2004. this was prompted by
disgust with the cynical manipulations
of elites
especially one in particular the
ukrainian opposition to the government
was led by viktor yushchenko earlier an
economist
and head of the central bank in ukraine
as candidate for the presidency
his coalition promised to fight
corruption
bring uk ukraine closer to the west and
to set the country on a new course
but then on september 5th 2004 yushenko
went to dinner
with the deputy head of the ukrainian
intelligence service
later that evening yushenko became
desperately ill
medical tests showed dioxin poisoning
symptoms
and the symptoms indeed were visible on
his bloated pockmarked face
who had done it several suspects fled to
russia
and could not be questioned was the
intention to kill him outright
and remove him from the presidential
campaign or was the intention
merely to disfigure him in his outward
appearance and thus
scuttle his chances for election
whatever the case
it backfired when the government
announced fraudulent election returns
people took to the streets they chose
that vivid color
orange to rally people to their cause
and flags and shirts
and they kept protesting even in that
bitter winter cold out in the streets
one in every five ukrainians went out in
protest
in the orange revolution but there were
contrasts there was that
divide between east and west one in
three people in the west
protested but fewer than one in 20 in
the eastern part of the country
in the capital kiev the demonstrations
rocked the city's independence square
the so-called maidan nezalesnosti
over 17 days the protesters finally won
and in a new election that was held
yushenko became
president yet what followed was a
disappointment
and that still puzzles experts trying to
understand why this was
rather than making common cause those
who had loudly championed reform
instead got bogged down in struggles
against one another
there was little sense of progress being
made capitalizing on people's
frustration
radical ukrainian nationalist groups
some of whom celebrated
step on bandera as a hero started to
gain more support
then in 2010 viktor yanukovych was
elected president
with most of his support based in the
eastern regions
and also with the support of russia's
leader vladimir putin
yanukovych told nato that ukraine which
had been considering membership before
was not interested in membership and
indeed the population was very
ambivalent
yanukovych also jailed his opponent
yulia timoshenko
a co-leader of the orange revolution and
a former prime minister accusing her
of corruption in office at the end of
2013
when yanukovych bizarrely first
negotiated and then refused to sign
an association agreement with the
european union
again mass protests erupted in kiev
leave and other cities centered once
again
on kiev's maidan these protests
in the coldest winter came to be
popularly called the euromaidan
or euro square protests
government forces tried to quell the
portrait of the
protests so-called berkut officers
were specially charged with crushing
demonstrations
the berkut were forces like the zomo
police had been
in poland or the oman special forces in
the soviet union
in the suppression of the protests
dozens of protesters were killed
but by february 2014 president
yanukovych
felt that his power was crumbling and he
fled
finding refuge in russia there then
followed
strange scenes as hundreds of thousands
of protesters
now wandered around in yanukovych's vast
estate near kiev an estate which
showcased the wealth of an
oligarch at its most ostentatious and
outrageous
the grand mansion had been built in a
rambling and eclectic bombastic style
that locals started calling donetsk
rococo
after yanukovych's hometown donetsk
the mansion was set on a larger
territory of 350 acres
it was surrounded by a private zoo of
exotic birds and deer
tennis courts a helicopter pad
and winding landscaped gardens with
pillared pavilions and pleasure domes
at this point the entire complex was
declared to be the property of the state
and plans were elaborated for using it
as a museum of corruption
but then questions of the ownership of
the estate got
bogged down illegal complications in the
courts
emblematic of the whole tangled
processes of government in ukraine
even after the overthrow of yanukovych
also emblematic of problems and
confusion was a mystery that surrounded
some of the loot
that was on display there persistent
rumors insisted that among yanukovych's
many toys
was a loaf of bread made of gold
but it disappeared in the looting and
tramping through the palace
and now officials claim that it never
really existed at all
putin who had been yanukovych's patron
declared his ouster
and the change of government in kiev
illegitimate
russian media denounced the protesters
as neo-fascists and nazis
they called them banderozzi recalling
world war
ii and the guerrilla leader step on
bandera
russian forces moved into crimea
at first the russian government denied
that it had sent troops into the region
which had an ethnic russian majority
the troops that arrived there were
joculy referred to as
little green men noah knew where they
were from
perhaps from mars they brought they bore
no insignia on their uniforms but they
did wear masks
russia then annexed crimea officially
over international protests
news reports suggested that inhabitants
of crimea
who opposed the annexation have faced
violence
and crimean tartars who make up some 15
percent of the population
are anxious about their own fate in
their own homeland once again
later in march of 2015 putin proudly
admitted openly
what his government had earlier denied
that he had masterminded the annexation
of crimea from the start
it was not a spontaneous response to
calls for help from locals
but a plan and the annexation in fact
had been ordered weeks before the
referendum
was staged under the watchful eyes of
gunmen
next heavily armed rebels many again
wearing masks
started seizing territories in eastern
ukraine along the russian border
and declaring many republics under their
control
they were self-appointed administrators
of this region and one observer
memorably labeled this the republic of
random dudes
russian media referred to the
territories by a new name
or rather revived an old name these were
called novoracia or new russia
precisely the name given to our next
lands by catherine the great
in july 2014 malaysia airlines flight 17
was shot down
as it crossed over eastern ukraine near
the border with russia
the plane had been bound from amsterdam
to kuala lumpur
and all 298 people on board perished
rebels at first did not allow
international investigators
to the crash site as fighting continued
russian officials insisted that none of
their soldiers were in ukraine
but when russian prisoners were taken it
was announced that in fact
they were soldiers on vacation who could
do what they wished in their own free
time
however the russian government went on
to declare
that the deaths of russian soldiers
during peacetime were a state secret
which opened to prosecution by the state
anyone who reported on funerals back in
russia
of men killed in ukraine
communal conflict also blazed up in
areas with mixed populations
a particularly dreadful incident took
place in the famed port city of odessa
with about 30 russian population in may
of 2014
pro-russian and pro-ukrainian protesters
clashed
and molotov cocktails were thrown
leading to the deaths of about 42
most of them of the pro-russian group a
full investigation was promised by the
ukrainian government
but was badly managed so the event still
remains unclear
by 2015 in spite of ceasefires
negotiated in minsk in belarus
and then broken before the ink was dry
the fighting had already taken some 5
000 lives
and had turned upwards of a million
people into refugees
civilians living on the front lines were
subjected to shelling
mortar attacks and cross fire a whole
zone of the country
now was dominated by a state of
undeclared war
and the question presented itself
whether one wanted it to or not
is this the new normal in europe
back in 2008 vladimir putin reportedly
told a
startled president george w bush during
a summit meeting
that ukraine is not really a country as
the crisis unfolded in
2014 the president of the european
commission
called putin in august to seek some
resolution to the crisis
putin's reported reply was that he could
occupy kiev in two weeks
the background to this perspective was
putin's declaration
that the soviet union's collapse was the
greatest tragedy
of the 20th century the cultural and
educational policies of putin's regime
have praised the soviet union and
revived
its symbolism and vocabulary the biting
irony here is that in fact
russians had been victimized by that
system longest
living under its control longer than
other peoples absorbed later
in eastern europe in that sense this
represents a hangover
from the end of soviet empire and
communism
yet putin's policies led to a surge in
his popularity back home
a deliberate manipulation of news and
media sought to sway public opinion in
russia and abroad
tv in russia aired interviews telling of
atrocities
one woman claimed that ukrainians had
crucified the infant son
of a rebel it was later learned that she
was the wife of a berkut officer
involved in suppressing protests
and the story was never confirmed nor
retracted
polemics surrounded the shooting down of
the malaysian airliner including
claims that everyone on board had been
dead already and that the incident was a
western provocation
putin's government argued that its
intervention was motivated only by
concerns for order in ukraine
which had become a failed state here
were fascinating historical echoes from
all the way back to the late 1700s when
the great powers
had justified carving up the state of
poland lithuania with
precisely the same claims one unspoken
reality was that in fact
disorder was encouraged by the outside
powers quite deliberately
a revival of civic order within the
target state would actually
threaten the partitioning power because
it would offer a
different and attractive alternative
form of government
but a key difference in this case was
that rather than a series of great
powers
looming over and vivisecting a country
here russia alone was taking the lead
the russian extreme nationalist
politician vladimir jeranovsky
leader of the bizarre bizarrely misnamed
liberal democratic party
slyly suggested that other countries
should join in
the news agency reuters reported that
gironovsky sent letters to the
governments of poland
hungary and romania urging them to also
annex parts of ukraine
that had once belonged to their states
jodanovsky announced that
it is never too late to correct
historical errors
whether meant as a deliberate prank or
sirius zhironovsky's musings were
attuned to the precedence of many
partitions
in the past of eastern europe of course
the most urgent question is what
precedents are being set now
for the future as western leaders
considered how to react they repeatedly
stated
how surprised they were and suggested
that putin must not know that we are
after all in the 21st century
he was acting in ways more fitting of
past centuries
such repeated observations are troubling
because they suggest the comforting but
false notion that
ages or centuries have their own logic
and spirit
that must move toward peace on the
contrary
leaders and people set the agenda for an
age
and there's no automatic default mode of
peace to rely on
in the absence of leadership no natural
law commands that the 21st century
should
usher in harmony the european union
and the united states condemned the
putin's regime's advances
and imposed sanctions on trade with
russia in some cases quite reluctantly
in spite of ukrainian requests they did
not deliver arms to help in defense
nato was now on the front line of the
confrontation and poland and the baltic
states in particular
urged vigilance and action nato's
concept of collective security is
written into article 5 of its charter
which states that an attack on one
member
would be considered an attack on all in
all of nato's life to date that promise
has been invoked only once
after the 9 11 attacks on the united
states
would that promise hold in the future
how would so-called
hybrid warfare that is infiltrations and
special operations
short of open invasion be met what role
would be played by
other potential flashpoints including
the isolated russian exclave of
kaliningrad
a nuclear-armed island surrounded by
nato and eu members
while these remained open questions one
tragic reality was clear
earlier ukrainians and russians were
bound by many ties in history
and proximate in language and
intermarriage as ukraine's independent
statehood began
a majority of ukrainians desired good
relations both with russia and the west
yet it is in the nature of war and
conflict that it forecloses many options
that peace might have offered
what the future offers the entire region
of eastern europe we shall explore in
our next
and final lecture